Written and directed by Leigh Whannell, The
Invisible Man is a rock-solid thriller, but
some of its mysteries are never fully resolved.
However, we'll be breaking down all of the
questions that the film never gave us answers
to, to see if we can answer them ourselves.
Pretty much every scene in The Invisible Man
is about Cecilia struggling, literally or
metaphorically, with Adrian's lingering presence
in her life.
The film's singular focus on this one plotline
is generally a good thing, since it offers
the audience no escape from the constantly
escalating tension.
But unfortunately, it also means that there's
basically no room in the film for subplots,
so we don't get a chance to learn much about
who Cecilia is as a person, outside of her
relationship with Adrian.
In the brief moments where Cecilia is momentarily
free of Adrian's grasp, we catch glimpses
of a truly compelling character who we want
to learn more about.
When she, James, and Sydney are just hanging
out together, Cecilia is sharp, funny, and
empathetic.
Also, in one scene, Cecilia is suddenly being
interviewed for a job at an architecture firm,
the only acknowledgement we get of Cecilia
having career aspirations.
Was she an architect before?
Did she give it up for Adrian?
One reason why Cecilia sometimes feels like
such a cipher is because even she herself
might not even know who she is anymore.
Trauma can make you feel like whoever you
once were, that person has now been erased.
You have no life outside your struggle for
survival.
Who was Cecilia before she met Adrian?
The film doesn't answer, and we'd really like
to know, but perhaps Cecilia is currently
in a place where not even she remembers.
From the moment Emily rescues Cecilia from
Adrian's house, something seems off about
their interactions.
Emily is never seen comforting her sister,
most of their conversations quickly turn to
bickering, and most tragically of all, when
strange things start happening to Cecilia,
Emily doesn't take her sister's concerns seriously.
One possible interpretation of their dynamic
is that it's solely a necessary plot device
in order for the horror of the film to function.
As is the case with many horror stories, the
scares can only continue if no one listens
to the protagonist.
But there's also a more charitable reading
of their dynamic.
Long before Cecilia escaped from Adrian, she
and Emily were already estranged.
Think about it, the way that Cecilia's stalker
drives a wedge between her and Emily is by
sending a single fake email, telling Emily
that Cecilia wishes she was dead.
What happens next?
Emily immediately cuts Cecilia out of her
life.
Cecilia denies that she sent the email, but
Emily refuses to listen.
If that email was a wildly out of character
thing for Cecilia to say, you'd think that
Emily would consider the possibility that
she didn't have the full picture, and she'd
listen to Cecilia's explanation.
Emily's reaction only makes sense if there
was already some underlying tension between
the sisters that Cecilia's tormentor was exploiting.
We never get the full story about the reason
for this tension, but some old wound is undeniably
there.
After Cecilia is arrested for her sister's
murder, a nurse meets with her and tells her
that, according to a blood test, Cecilia is
pregnant.
The nurse says,
"The test shows us that it was pretty recent.
We can't be sure of exactly when, but it must
have been some time in the last month."
So now comes an unpleasant question...when
and how did Cecilia get pregnant?
At this point, we don't know exactly how long
it's been since Cecilia escaped from Adrian.
Two weeks passed between when she first left
and when she heard of his apparent suicide.
Since then, we're guessing that at least a
few more weeks have probably elapsed, if not
significantly longer, perhaps even a couple
months.
It's possible, though a bit of a stretch,
that Adrian got Cecilia pregnant while they
were still living together, but it's also
possible that, and here's where things get
real uncomfortable, he did so after she'd
already left.
We don't want to think about the mechanics
of how exactly that would work, but given
what we know about Adrian, both in terms of
his immorality and his resourcefulness, it's
not out of the question.
One other lingering question that the film
doesn't answer is what's going to happen to
Cecilia's unwanted pregnancy?
We can understand why the film didn't go there,
but whether or not Cecilia plans on keeping
it is perhaps one of the biggest questions
that the film chooses to leave unanswered.
When Cecilia finally shoots the invisible
assailant in James' house and peels the suit
off him, she's surprised to find not Adrian
inside but rather his simpering toad of a
brother, Tom.
There are a few different ways to interpret
this reveal.
One is that Tom really was the one tormenting
Cecilia all this time, and Adrian never got
his hands dirty personally.
Another interpretation is that this is the
only time Tom wears the suit, perhaps because
Adrian is attempting to frame him, but at
all other points, Adrian is the only one abusing
her.
Either of these explanations are potentially
defensible, but there's another interesting
option.
It's also possible that, during the final
invasion of James' house (and perhaps earlier),
there are two invisible men, Tom and Adrian,
working together simultaneously.
After all, when Sydney finally confronts the
invisible man in her room by macing him, he
collapses to the ground, but then, a moment
later, when Sydney runs out into the hallway,
she's immediately knocked over.
It's possible that it's the same guy, but
the logistics of the scene make way more sense
if there was actually a second invisible man
waiting in the hallway.
We know that Adrian has access to multiple
suits.
And don't forget, when Adrian is discovered
by police the next day, his eyes look awfully
red.
Perhaps like someone who was recently maced?
Throughout much of the film, Adrian and his
brother, Tom, appear to be in a more or less
equal partnership, a unified front of awfulness.
But occasionally, we get hints that their
relationship might be a lot more complicated.
At one point, Tom asserts that Adrian held
all the power in their relationship, saying,
"My brother controlled me long before he met
you, Cecilia."
Later, after Tom is killed, Adrian claims
that the complete opposite is true, saying,
"I know it didn't seem like it to the outside
world, but Tom controlled me."
If both brothers claim that they were the
abused and powerless party in a toxic relationship,
who should we believe?
We feel the evidence points towards Tom being
subservient to Adrian and not the other way
around.
When Tom visits Cecilia in the psych ward,
he tells her that they can get her out of
jail if she agrees to return to her life with
Adrian.
This ultimatum doesn't really make sense if
Tom has the power and Adrian is just a puppet.
That being said, it's also potentially true
that both brothers are telling the truth,
at least in part.
Maybe they each abused one another at various
times.
Or perhaps both are lying, and their claims
of abuse exist solely to manipulate Cecilia's
emotions.
Regardless, none of this justifies the way
that either of them behaves, so it also seems
safe to just label them both as irredeemable
jerks and move on with our lives.
Since there's still arguably a bit of ambiguity
at the end of the film regarding just how
bad of a guy Adrian is, is Cecilia's decision
to murder him truly justifiable?
During Adrian and Cecilia's final dinner conversation,
Cecilia is wearing a wire to record their
conversation.
Presumably, she's doing this to attempt to
trick Adrian into confessing his crimes on
tape, so that she can send him to jail.
Adrian, however, is evasive, and he starts
trying to seduce and gaslight Cecilia all
over again.
This culminates with him using the phrase,
"That shouldn't come as a surprise."
As Adrian says these words, a twinge of realization
flashes across Cecilia's face, presumably
because this has just confirmed two things
for her.
The first comes from how he says that word,
"surprise," in his deep, raspy voice.
That same word was used mockingly by Cecilia's
invisible stalker as he was tormenting her,
and hearing that word again in Adrian's voice
presumably confirms for her that they are
the same person.
We can also assume that this confirms for
Cecilia that Adrian is still willing to lie
to her, willing to start up the cycle of abuse
all over again.
Adrian truly has no remorse, no conscience,
and he's never going to stop.
That was enough for Cecilia to conclude that
Adrian needed to die.
Does that make what she did right?
In the end, Cecilia decides to kill Adrian
by putting on an invisibility suit and forcing
him to cut his own throat with a knife, in
full view of the house's security cameras,
so that he appears to be committing suicide.
It's a shocking and gut-wrenching moment,
but it also has the potential to be somewhat
confusing.
After all, the exact logistics of how Cecilia
accomplished this plan aren't ever fully explained.
When and how exactly did she get her hands
on an invisibility suit of her own?
One option is that Cecilia is wearing Tom's
suit from when he attacked James' house.
However, this seems unlikely for two reasons.
First, the suit was clearly damaged after
Cecilia shot it to pieces.
The second problem is that Tom's suit was
presumably turned over to the police as evidence.
What seems to be a far more likely option
is that Cecilia's suit is actually the one
that she discovered earlier in the basement
when she crept back into Adrian's house halfway
through the film.
In this scene, she peels it off a mannequin,
presumably to steal it, but when she hears
someone entering the house, Cecilia appears
to stash the suit away in an air vent inside
Adrian's closet.
Later, when Cecilia claims that she's going
to the bathroom during her dinner with Adrian,
she's most likely retrieving the suit from
the closet and using it to execute her master
plan.
After Cecilia's final confrontation with Adrian,
the film ends rather abruptly.
Even though, in this moment, Cecilia seems
to have found some measure of closure, we
still have endless questions about what comes
next for her.
First, is Cecilia going to jail for any of
the stuff she's done?
She may not have actually committed her sister's
murder, but she did break out of a mental
hospital, and she did kill both Tom and Adrian.
However, we think she's going to be just fine.
Numerous people "saw" an invisible suspect
menacing Cecilia in the hospital, which means
shooting Tom was legitimately self-defense.
Plus, her plan for eliminating Adrian was
rock solid.
And if things go bad, Cecilia also just inherited
$5 million, so she can probably afford some
pretty good lawyers.
One of the reasons that The Invisible Man
has been so critically well-received is because
it succeeds on numerous different levels simultaneously.
It's not just a vehicle for scares.
It's also a film with a brain, full of deeper
themes about trauma and abuse.
But what exactly is it trying to say about
these subjects?
First, in regards to trauma, the film shows
us that even when the source of your pain
is gone, trauma stays with you like an invisible
monster.
We see that this is the case for Cecilia even
before the invisible man comes back into her
new life.
She's afraid to leave the house, she has trouble
sleeping, and she jumps at shadows.
Metaphorically, Cecilia's tormentor is a personification
of trauma, an invisible force that stands
at the foot of her bed at night, follows her
down the street, and pulls her away from her
friends and family.
And second, in regards to abuse, The Invisible
Man shows us that when people come forward
and claim that they're being abused, we tend
not to believe them.
We downplay their stories, invalidate their
feelings, and call them "crazy."
Pretty much everyone in the film does this
to Cecilia at some point, even her sister
and her friend.
This film is a reminder that just because
we can't see the people around us being abused,
that doesn't mean it isn't happening.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about horror
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.